the second impeachment trial of now
former president donald trump is set to
begin
in the senate next month democrats
amended the timetable last night after
several days of back and forth with
republicans who suggested both sides
could use more time
the move may be setting the tone for
more deal making and a quicker
confirmation to president biden's
cabinet nominees in the 50-50 senate
chris vancleave is on capitol hill
for the second time in just over a year
an article of impeachment against
president donald trump will be walked
across the capitol
and delivered to the senate monday
immediately triggering the start of the
former president's trial
the senate will conduct a trial of the
impeachment of donald trump
it will be a full trial it will be a
fair trial
majority leader chuck schumer announced
the trial will begin the second week of
february
minority leader mitch mcconnell who has
blamed mr trump for the assault was
pushing for such a delay
we need a full and fair process where
the former president can mount a defense
and the senate can properly consider the
factual
legal and constitutional questions
president biden today said he was open
to a delay as it would give the senate
more time to approve his cabinet the
more time we have to get up and running
and meet these crises
the better senate democrats need 17
republicans to join them to convict mr
trump
none are yet on board and some are
questioning having
a trial at all it's unconstitutional it
sets a bad president for the
presidency and it continues to divide
the nation
the national guard protecting the
capital got a visit from the first lady
who brought cookies and thanked them for
their efforts
over half of the nearly 26 thousand
troops in washington will start heading
home in the coming days
but thursday night thousands found
themselves booted out of the capitol by
police and moved to a parking garage
members of congress were outraged and
got the soldiers back inside
within hours the capitol police and
national guard came out with a joint
statement essentially making nice saying
they are united in a common mission
we have learned that at least 38 capital
police officers and about 150 national
guardsmen
have come down with covid since the
january sixth siege on the capitol that
was led by a largely maskless crowd
for cbs this morning saturday chris van
cleave
washington